thanks for tuning in to this special
edition of Google developers live today
we're featuring Hadi partovi from code
org
in celebration of computer science
education week you can find out more
about computer science education week
and the hour of code campaign at Sea sed
week org hi my name is Mamie Rheingold
and I am your host for this special
edition of Google developers live our
guest today is Hadi partovi and after
getting his bachelor's and master's in
computer science from Harvard he went on
to Microsoft in 1994 where he joined a
small team to grow Internet Explorer
he is cents advised and invested in
multiple startups including Dropbox and
Facebook and he's also founded many
companies of his own the most recent of
which is code.org so howdy
I'd love to start by hearing more from
you about why should we all care about
computer science what is your vision
with code org and tell us more about
this week's hour of code events sure
well er did code.org was a realization
that computers are now everywhere
they're not just on your desktop and you
know on your laptops or at work they're
in your pockets they're in your cars
they're in your appliances they're there
literally all over the place and every
industry in the world depends on
software whether it's transportation
agriculture food and yet the vast
majority of Americans have no idea how
these things work and the vast majority
of schools don't even offer courses in
introducing these these things to you
and you know a lot of people think that
code overhaul means like this are
designed to basically produce more
software engineers to get jobs at
companies like Google and you know
that's a side effect of people learning
how to code my main vision is that every
student in every school should have Bob
unity to learn not because they want to
get a job at Google and computer science
you know it is a class that you can take
and get a great job but more importantly
it's a class that you should take if you
want to become a doctor in the 21st
century or if you want to become a
lawyer or a journalist or even the
president every career that you can
think of in the
day world should have some background in
this great and so what are what are
these hour of code events the our code
was are coming together of a number of
ideas we had for how to promote computer
science not just to students but to
parents into teachers to help remove the
veil that of mystery that separates the
average person from the mark zuckerberg
zuv a genius coders of the world and to
help everybody learn that not only this
is important to learn but that it's easy
to learn that a seven-year-old can start
basic computer programming and starting
with that idea we thought what if we
could get millions of students in
schools and communities worldwide to try
to learn just one hour of computer
science and how can we bring the best
companies organizations celebrities
governments to come to bear to basically
grow this into a real movement hmm and
so since this is about learning to code
um when did you first learn to code the
very very first computer program I wrote
was on a programmable calculator I think
when I was around eight years old and my
first computer I got when I was about 10
years old was a Commodore 64 and my dad
gave me this computer you know yeah
there was no games on it out we were
living in Iran where you couldn't even
buy a computer in that country it was
sort of imported from Italy and he said
if you want to play any games I don't
you have to write them yourself and my
twin brother and I immediately started
finding magazines that had sort of basic
programs and you could type into the
computer to create your own game and
then starting from there and we learned
how to change the games and write our
own cool I just took two months off to
learn how to code and like learning
anything new it it can be hard and for
me it was like learning to see and think
in a whole new way and sometimes an hour
could take I could take just an hour to
understand the problem I was trying to
solve so tell me more about what you're
envisioning kids doing in an hour of
code so you know as you've learned
yourself from doing it coding and
writing computer programs isn't about
learning a new language and the average
computer language has about 50 words in
it and I could
heard a lot more to Legos you know when
you when you use Legos it's not like
there's 10,000 different Lego blocks
there's about 50 different major blocks
but the art is in how you build
something complicated using that limited
set of commands and the most important
thing a kid can learn in one hour of
writing code is to realize that there's
not a lot to memorize and it's more
about solving problems and creating
whatever you want and and unleashing the
creativity and empowering it good to
realize wow I can actually do this stuff
that's their number one goal at the end
of one hour cool yeah and and so and for
those kids that know they don't want to
be engineers they don't want to grow up
to be a computer science why should they
participate at least 95 don't want to
grow up and become a software engineer
and our goal is to get all of them to
learn the basics and the basics of
computer science mean not just learning
how to code but also learning how does
the internet work what's a virus or a
software virus you know when I went to
high school every single school and
every single student taught and learned
how electricity works or how to dissect
a frog to see the digestive system and
in this century schools should teen how
do you effectively dissect an apt to
learn the insides outs of that and
that's relevant if you want to become a
doctor health care is dominated now by
technology if you want to become a
lawyer
understanding IP law or understanding
how you're gonna regulate things like
the the NSA you know we see our
government stumbling with efforts and
technology and it's not because they
need to become software engineers but
they need to have at least more of a
basic understanding than the absolute
zero that our schools currently offer so
it's like the physics or the biology of
the digital world exactly you know this
year's Nobel Prize winners in chemistry
were computer scientists it's the best
way of realizing this is a field that
impacts everything hmm I love that and
since this is Google developers live we
a lot of developers out there tuning in
and so what what can these looking
people who are already developers what
can they do to help your mission with
code org so most developers
automatically jump to think this is
awesome you know if you're already a
developer you already realized that you
you have a special power that most
people don't and that you can harness
thousands of computers to do your
bidding and you know which is a kind of
an unusual thing but you know it's that
there is no other skill that helps
amplify the creativity of the human mind
the way computer programming does and
sharing that as something that
developers very naturally want to do the
best ways to do that are to to basically
get people in your community especially
your local school but if not a local
school and after-school club like a Boy
Scouts or Girl Scouts or so on to add
computer science it's harder to get
schools to do this because they're
they're government organizations but Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts and Boys and
Girls Clubs and so on readily can engage
in this stuff to make it easier for
developers we've got a sign-up page
where engineers can sign up as
volunteers to say I want to get involved
which will then actually then help local
communities who want a software
engineers and mentor come in pull em in
we've also released a 20 hour online
course that sort of as an after you know
something that comes after the first
hour of code to teach you 20 hours worth
of more computer programming and also
learning about things like how the
internet works and that's an online
course you can teach to your kids and
your family members or bring to a local
school or Club cool and also our
developer community is global and I
noticed that um for our of code it says
you don't even need a computer to
participate so I want to learn more
about that how can people participate if
they don't have access to computers or
the Internet
yes so there's both you can do it if you
don't have a computer you could do it if
you don't have the internet we've we've
tried to solve for all versions of this
stuff if you have absolutely nothing
there's paper and pen exercises where
somebody can write programs on a piece
of paper and it's more like a sort of
social exercise where one kid pretends
like they're the computer managing a
robotic arm doing what another kids
program is telling them to do and then
we have a bunch of puzzles like how does
the robotic arm take
stack of cups and then build a Christmas
tree pattern out of them you know and
one kid nice all right the program for
the other kid to execute to do that now
in a lot of the modern world people have
computers but they don't have great
internet connectivity or they don't have
lots of computers but our tutorials work
we have tutorials that work on an
offline computer or on a smartphone or a
tablet smartphones are pretty popular
these days and you can learn to code on
one and that that's a great way to start
yeah it's actually when I was I've been
learning to code like writing things out
in white boarding has been actually like
the first step for anything just
understand what is it that we're trying
to do and map out how to how to break
code to do that it's all about problem
solving it forces you to organize your
thoughts better than most other things
you learn and it's interesting that the
ability to organize your thoughts and to
break a big problem down into smaller
problems is really useful even if what
you want to become a lawyer or or
manager you know learning how to break
down a problem is really valuable for
learning how to build a team and manage
who does what they're very related
skills yeah
applies to everything it's like
essential life skill and so what happens
if if 10 million kids all learn to code
what is that what does that future look
like to you um first of all hopefully
our servers will hold up yeah you know
we we don't know how many people are
gonna hit our site ad for the day hour
of code but it's it's a little
frightening em but 10 million kids learn
at least the basics of computer science
I think a number of things will happen
first of all we'll hit an inflection
point of effectively whether the school
system wants it or not the world
audience is gonna start learning coding
and computer science at a larger scale
than they have been you know a large
percentage of the population has some
familiarity with this stuff I think
you're gonna see fewer
I guess well you'll see more innovation
in every field soft work and create
innovation we just heard about Amazon
using drones to
deliver packages you know we hear about
nanobots being used in your bloodstream
to to cure illnesses by having a little
you know robotic thing in your blood
doing stuff to you the hardest
challenges and most of these things are
actually in the software and in the code
you know building a drone is easy
programming that drone so it doesn't run
into a tree that's actually where it's
hard or or how it communicates with
other drones so they don't hit each
other so whether you think about
transportation communication medicine
agriculture food all over in every
industry it's the software that actually
is is driving with the innovation and so
after after this week then what where do
you want to where do you want to see
code or go from here so code.org is a
surprisingly small organization we have
about I think 16 full-time employees
that where we have a lot of ambition and
a lot of big ideas there's at least four
different things we're gonna be doing
after the hour of code one we have
curriculum at the elementary school
level that we've built in partnership
with Google and Microsoft and Facebook
and Twitter employees but we want to
extend that to up to curriculum tools
they go all the way from kindergarten
through twelfth grade that's point one
point two is actually getting this into
public schools by fall of next year we
should have basically put computer
science into about 400 schools but we
want to get to 4,000 schools and 40,000
schools so that's a multi-year effort
bringing computer science into schools
and then the third thing we're working
on is changing policies in 36 states in
the country computer science doesn't
count towards high school graduation
requirements in math math or science and
that's actually a great way developers
can help petition their school board
saying why don't you fix the graduation
rule so computer science is treated as a
math or science or so we're lobbying and
and then lastly we're gonna continue do
marketing to help get underrepresented
groups to engage in computer science
more especially girls and minorities
cool these are a big big problems who
are trying to solve what are there's
been any obstacles along the way I mean
education policy those are big big
systems who are changing yeah it's funny
on the policy side things you know
anytime you want to try to change a
system you expect obstacles I've never
worked on anything where there have
there's been such an sort of engagement
of people embracing what we're doing and
getting behind it at the policy level
we've changed on the order of six states
in six months which is unheard yeah
that's really really fast because
there's the opposition is non-existent
nobody says oh no we shouldn't be doing
this
the hardest opposition though we have
isn't changing the public schools to
offer a new class and because their
mindset is literally if we add this what
are we gonna need to cut and I've had
conversations with districts heads of
curriculum where they say you know I
guess this is an elective so we need to
probably cut another elected what if we
cut ceramics what are those kids who
want to do ceramics going to do and you
know I have so I'm just overwhelmed just
thinking well first of all they can
learn ceramics in an after-school class
let's teach computer science in the real
school there's no jobs in ceramics
there's a million jobs in computer
science over the next ten years and then
lastly why don't with it let the kids
decide you know why is the school
deciding that isn't available but
ceramics is you know if if you have to
make a choice choose the one that is
going to be more popular let the kids
decided rather than you decided but
either way that's by far our hardest
obstacle is finding school districts who
are willing to create change
hmm and so what are just to recap what
are the things that folks can do after
they watch this if they're inspired to
help you and your mission how can I help
how people can help the easiest way is
signed a petition at code org the next
easiest way is do an hour of code
yourself or if you know it already do it
with a brother a sister a daughter or a
son or your mother had harder ways you
know you can spend some money and buy
one of our t-shirts to help promote out
code especially if you're a girl and and
the best way you can help if you're an
engineer is get your local school to
teach computer science
fools on our website to help you do that
to help you advocate for that
that's great hottie thank you for
joining us and thank you all for tuning
in
make sure to join in on the fun at
code.org during computer science
education week